contraire qu'il faut faire.
C'est la technique vipère.
Attendre la fin pour rentrer à
tour de rôle. C'est peut-être
compétitif, mais c'est ce qu'il
faut faire comme nous l'explique
Kim Vermette.
- Il faudrait qu'ils
.c vérif. 2:07
- C'est l'enfer, pour vrai.
Ça jamais été aussi pire,
je pense.
- C'est à peu près une heure par
jour qu'on peut perdre, avec les
détours, les trafic maintenant,
comparé à avant.
- Il faudrait qu'ils
aboutissent un jour.
- Et puis, il y a le panneau qui
indique la fermeture d'une voie
de circulation et qui souvent
provoque des bouchons monstres.
Alors, qu'est-ce qu'on doit
faire? Rester dans la voie qui
est ouverte coûte que coûte?
Ou bien s'y faufiler
à la dernière minute?
- La méthode Zipper
pourrait nous épargner
quelques maux de tête.
- La méthode du Zipper est très
simple : un véhicule dans la
voie qui ferme, un véhicule
dans la voie qui circule,
et tour à tour, comme les dents
d'une fermeture éclair.
MARCO HARRISON, expert
en sécurité routière
On parle, dans les études
américaines, entre autres,
d'une réduction de 40 à 50 %
des distances ou des longueurs
de file d'attente au niveau
de la congestion.
- L'Allemagne et la Belgique
ont déjà intégré la pratique
à leur code de la route.
Au pays, la ville de Saskatoon
a aussi règlementé
la méthode zipper.
- C'est logique. De là
à l'obliger, au niveau du code
de la sécurité routière, c'est
une autre paire de manches.
Je pense que de bien éduquer,
de bien sensibiliser les gens
à cette méthode-là, à leur
demander de l'utiliser
de la meilleure façon possible
lorsqu'ils arrivent dans une
congestion, ils vont le faire.
- Et puis, Yves,
ça regarde comment?
- Ça ne va pas bien du tout.
- Ah non, pas encore!
- Sur la route matin et soir,
Yves Désautels est à même
de le constater.
Les chantiers compliquent
la circulation, et l'impatience
de certains automobilistes
est palpable.
YVES DESAUTELS, chroniqueur
circul., Radio-Canada Première
- Est-ce que c'est dû à la
pandémie? Est-ce que c'est
dû à l'anxiété, la frustration?
Il y a plus d'accident,
on dirait, qu'avant. C'est
souvent la vitesse, et les gens
se suivent de trop près.
- Avec la rentrée scolaire,
le retour au bureau et la saison
des chantiers loin d'être
terminée, patience et courtoisie
sont de mise. Pourquoi donc
ne pas garder en tête
cette méthode zipper?
Ici Kim Vermette,
Radio-Canada, M